all right
we're live here no no don't know what
happened there san francisco believe it
or not bad internet
all right guys thank you for joining uh
really excited for today
to talk about the hasidic series i just
finished on it's a 13 part series
and wow it was really a wild ride and
super excited to connect with you guys
today
answer any questions you might have i
won't probably be able to get to them
all
um if you do send a super chat and i
miss it i will get to it at the end of
the live stream
okay so i want to make sure every every
super check gets answered
and uh yeah so a lot of people have
asked me
uh so peter why did you shoot a series
on the hasidic jews or how did you get
into it
so the short story is i was living
overseas in ukraine
and doing a lot of global content
had plans for israel palestine
syria and lebanon this last spring and
then the pandemic happened
and travel became very difficult so my
wife and i were thinking of moving to
italy because i'm italian too i have an
italian passport
and then we were like well what are we
going to get for content there
and we moved back to the us
so then i've become very fascinated with
the us uh
living outside of it for four years and
i was going to new york
and i posted on my stories hey
you know anyone have any interesting
ideas in new york city for videos
and shlomi as many of you know shlomi
the legend
reached out and said hey do you want to
see what the hasidic world is like
and uh that's right up my alley i love i
love subcultures i love the unknown
and i love the underdog and that clicked
all the boxes ticked all the boxes
i knew nothing about hasidum as i've
mentioned before i knew
unorthodox the the netflix series
and i knew the guy that cut me off in
the airport and who was super rude
and that was it that was my story of uh
my narrative of his sedum and i knew
there's much more to it obviously but
that was my only interaction
so getting into this world through
shalomi
shlomi who i call shlo by the way that's
i might say slo that means shlomi that's
behind the scenes the nickname for
shlomi
uh well that was an eye-opener right and
uh
as some of you have seen we got down the
rabbit hole a little bit into
all different aspects of hasidum
now this was a 13-part series
usually i do like you know whatever
country i'm in i usually do like
six or seven maybe eight so this was
much longer
some people are like hey you gotta do
more do way more of
hasita and others are like hey peter
how many times can you shoot this story
get on to something else
i'll never make everyone happy i
understand but this is this is it for a
long time
uh as far as the hisidic world goes
and the reason i went so so many videos
on this is because when you have access
to uh
let's just call it what it is it's very
much closed off to the outside world
you know for a non-jew when you have
access you sort of have to make the most
of it
and so shlomi and i made
three videos the first time i was in new
york i i
went back to san francisco where i live
and then he reached out and he said hey
peter this is doing pretty well people
are really interested i can get you
deeper into the
acidic world uh what do you think and i
was like yeah i already did three videos
it's probably
probably enough here and then i thought
through and i'm like wow that's that's
sort of a one-in-a-lifetime opportunity
i'd be an idiot not to take them up on
it so by the end of that day i actually
made my decision
got plane ticket went back to new york
and then shot what
six or seven more videos something like
that and
i try to hit different aspects of it to
the best of my ability
and as an outsider yeah i can't say i'm
any expert by any stretch
uh if you if any of you want to ask me
deep religious questions i'm not the
go-to guy here
uh but i am here to answer questions
about
you know what is what was it like for me
how was the experiences
uh how was the experience thoughts of it
all those sorts of things
you can shoot them at me now i just want
to let you know i'm not much of a pro at
the live streams
so i got to scroll through
and see the comments here okay cool
gotcha gotcha gotcha
cool a lot of you here thank you thanks
for jumping on i appreciate it
okay action kid thanks action good peter
super awesome series in the city
community watch everyone but my favorite
was uh
shabbos dinner yeah that was um
what a special treat right like being
able to get into that and so i've been
told it was
it's almost impossible to do and the way
we had to shoot it was
was was was interesting right i couldn't
put the camera on someone and ask them a
question so it was a little bit maybe
awkward
looking from uh watching the video but
that's how we had to do it that's how
the rabbis proved it
yeah and i think i think it touched a
lot of people
the shabbos video because um
i think it's something it's something
deeper i think it's something we all
want
right now especially with this last year
this pandemic
all the politics going on uh being
separate
from people and that was a window into
you know an environment where no one was
scared about covet because since they
all had covet
and there'll be a few people you can get
covetous get covered yes you can but
it's very very rare so the the the fear
is completely removed on that front
then you have a family that's together
that's very tight-knit
and they had a couple friends in there
and so it was just this festive
environment that i haven't
felt for a long time and i think that's
what people felt too
so yeah action kid and guys action kid
is uh
if you don't know him he's got a great
youtube channel he walks all over new
york city does
does really like voyeuristic on the
ground interesting content
okay what's next um well we're going to
get into the acidic stuff here but i'll
answer that what's next
i'm going to do a couple videos in san
francisco here it's been hard with the
pandemic so we're going to go to la
but that got cancelled it's it's
difficult to shoot videos there right
now so
uh doing a couple here in san francisco
and then miami florida so deep in on
florida
i really want to get into the cuban
community there in other stories but
let's talk about hasidum first
uh ethan julian as a jew i found more
about has seen him through your videos
than anyone
else ah thanks man that's that's
interesting um
you know and as as you can see i was a
rookie
a lot of you were rookies in this world
just like myself
and that we sort of discovered it
together i didn't go in with a lot of
knowledge
and you know i did a little bit of
research
but i honestly want to bring you guys
the viewers through the same journey as
i'm going through
i didn't want to go in as an expert uh
so
i'm glad that that that people got
something out of it like i did
okay jen it's inspiring to me more
wholesome with my family after watching
your episodes oh that's cool
what did i think about the rabbi talking
about marriage a good question
so the rabbi made a lot of sense
i i didn't agree with everything he said
uh
i didn't agree what he said about the
self in the individual
i thought i mean i differed with him on
that but a lot of his
his principles and ways of looking at
relationships
i think make a lot of sense i'm married
now it took me until
uh 40 i'm 43 so i got married at 42.
i might not be the poster child to how
to do it right but
i'm happily married now and i'm in a
great relationship and i
you know maybe late to the party on as
far as uh
grounding down a lot of these principles
but i i get i get what he was saying
i think there was a lot of wisdom that
he shared with us
okay thank you moshi
and mobin thank you appreciate the from
the uk
that's great a lot of people from the uk
were in on this series
uh
okay some more questions uh is there
anything i learned this is from abby
uh keith kefe or keith is there anything
i learned about the community and wanted
to
adopt myself yes good question
so shabbos like
shabbat people ask me you're saying it
wrong well shabbos is either yiddish
or hebrew shabbat is either yiddish or
hebrew
english it's sabbath there's many names
for it
um that's something i think
we could all use and now i
i understand there's a lot of work
behind the scenes it all looks fun on
the video but there's a lot of
preparation
there's a lot of there's a lot of
discipline in that
when i have a family i would like to do
something like that
i think a day of just completely
removing yourself
is is like needed almost i want to get
to that
that's something i really learned about
the community there was also a woman
that uh got rid of her smartphone
i can't get there yet because i'm doing
all this social media stuff
but i think i i respect that i admire
that there's a lot to be learned with
like just looking at the simple things
and staying true to yourself
i found a lot of authenticity in the
community the hasidic world nobody's
faking
or pretending anything i'm sure they're
people that
there are people that have bounced out
of it and i'm sure there are young
people that want to be rebellious and
there's all different types but as a
whole i would say
it was um it was refreshing
how about that i would never have
thought i would say that in these times
especially refreshing
in san francisco we're locked down not
meaning we can't go outside but
like psychologically people seem to be
locked down nobody's smiling nobody's
looking at each other everyone's in a
heightened state of fear and going into
the
hasidic world was like ah this
this is nice this is relaxed and how
about that right how about that for
irony i'm in the so far most progressive
you know uh forward i'm definitely using
these air quotes because i don't think
it is right now forward thinking
uh places in the western world
and to feel free and relaxed i i go to
the so-called most conservative and
repressed
quote part of the country the hasidic
world
so those things have totally flipped on
themselves
well there's a ton i could answer out of
that one for sure i could talk for hours
on what i learned there
um how how chris k asked how has it
influenced me
um how i'd raise my children in the
future
i think uh structure you know i
the older i get i realize this is this
is more important
uh just the the the structure that
uh hasidum has i think is very important
and i think
i think kids need it and i think the way
society is pushing
now this is sort of a blanket state
statement but you know
a little bit away from that structure i
don't think is healthy so
the hasidic world has that nailed down
okay guys okay i'm clicking on these
chats
okay david g says we are non-religious
jews living in new york but it's been a
large part of our life in asia and we
have traveled to tons of countries in
the world
we watch every step in on our couch with
my wife's son and parents okay thank you
david no question there but thank you
uh and that's there's a good point there
david is in asia traveled a lot
and uh people from all over the world
are very interested
in the hasidic world i think you know
whatever is not known whatever somewhat
behind closed doors or secretive is
always interesting
and it's been perceived a certain way to
the outside world
and so there's two things going here i
think
i i have to answer this a lot um you
know
peter do you know that people have left
the community and they're unhappy and
there's all sorts of bad stuff that
happens
yes of course this is this is this is
humanity right
and i it's not for everyone i i will
straight up say
um that strict of a structure is not for
everyone
and everyone you know i'm not going to
speak for anyone
um what i was trying to do is show
show what i saw i'm obviously not going
to go into someone's
uh terrible history and make this
terrible story about i see them i feel
like
you know 99 of the the content out there
is negative about it so i'm like okay
can i shine some light in a different
way here and but i
do want to repeat there's all types of
stories that exist in the community just
because i posted uh you know this is a
very happy family doesn't mean everyone
every family is happy there are families
that aren't
and that's the same for you know what am
i i'm a wasp
white angle of anglo-saxon protestant
uh tell me there aren't broken families
and messed up stuff in that in that
large community so
yeah it's it's uniform across humanity
there are going to be good stories and
bad stories
uh i forget what the question was but
i'll move on in the next one okay uh
smile it's simple
yeah that's uh thank you i appreciate it
and that's a great message right now
that we all need it's um
look i think like all of you i don't
know i've been going on some rabbit
holes a little bit lately when i'm not
working and it's just
the world seems so just
depressing in a way right and uh
this has been my antidote to not
uh not say lose it but just going down a
negative spiral so my antidote has been
to get into
these community like the hasidic world
or different communities in a positive
aspect and so
it helps my psychology and by doing so i
i hope it helps people that are watching
their psychology is like a little bit of
relief
from everything else or most things that
are online right now
um uh tis vb
what organization blew me away the most
i liked chaverum
uh for those that don't know riveram is
like a
it's like an ambulance slash triple no
no it's it
is an ambulance like you know grandma
has problems with their plumbing
uh you break down on the side of the
road and
all sorts of little things they come out
and help and i just love that that
was a a beautiful aspect of the
community
is how they're all these things for the
community which means
there's structure and there's safety
nets to some degree
i felt like i'm sure they're outcasts
again i'm going to preface
all this stuff by not i'm speaking in
generalities there are
outcasts but overall i felt
not many people are slipping through the
cracks if i go downtown here in san
francisco a lot of people are
are slipping through the cracks really
hard
so you know organizations like that
really impressed me and they have
different security
organizations they have an ambulance i'm
forgetting the name of it an ambulance
organization like that
but pretty much everything's covered oh
and for the the kids
with uh special needs that sort of stuff
uh missile god i'm forgetting the
pronunciation on that okay
but yeah i think you guys know what i
mean if you saw that video there's like
organizations helping kids that have
you know challenges and you know
life limiting type stuff you know and
they're giving them
some beauty and uh hope you know despite
the circumstances
all right guys a lot of great questions
here i'd love to answer all but i can't
um i'll try not to repeat
okay uh rafi love your videos peter i'm
a jew living in the uk why don't you
visit more modern jewish orthodox
community
yeah i i should i really focused on
hasidum
judaism i tried to mention this in my
videos but it
unless you show it's not as powerful
you know judaism's like this for the
non-jews the jews know this but for the
non-jews like myself
it's like you have uh sasha baro cohen
over here
you know you have the burning man crowd
uh
free love whatever psychedelic drugs
and you have hasetum over here
which is what i showed and i couldn't
even get on the con
on the conservative hacienda that's not
happening right and even in hasidum
there's satmar
which is the most conservative good luck
on trying to get in on a satmar
shabbat like good luck on that i would
do it if i could
but i don't think that's going to happen
so even in a sedum there's these
different ranges within it
and then judaism is this wide
so uh orthodoxy i i from my
understanding is like
let's call it the notch down as far as
uh rules and code that someone needs to
live by
it's very conservative but not as
conservative as hasidim correct me if
i'm wrong here
i'd love to get in all of it at this
point this is the last of my
uh my jewish content for a while i've
uh you know the world audience i've
given a good window into this world but
i have to um
the show must go on let's call it that
okay james thank you thank you so much
um meditating in cars without coffee
interesting name did you ask about
kabbalah in the hasidic
community i didn't i didn't and i didn't
go too much
i was trying to sort of um
i felt like i would have lost too many
non-jews if i went deep into like deep
into the religion
i just felt like you know unless
someone's really interested in religion
i'm gonna lose them what i really
focused on was like daily life how
people live how people look at things
what does it feel like what does it look
like
okay thank you um arinda
you looks like indian rupees i think
those are rupees thank you
i appreciate it yeah guys so
the the people that came out in these
videos are the real stars honestly they
took the risk
i'm used to getting abused online or
whatever i mean it's the internet this
is how things go
these people that came out in all of
these videos a
they're taking the risk in their
community b they're taking the risk of
never really being on camera and being
exposed
to the world and the internet and what
comes with that
those are the true heroes in all of this
peter i'm a cuban-american if you need
any contacts help in miami
yes i do uh please contact at
petersantonello.com and just write cuba
on the top i would love that
yes all right guys some more questions
um can us jews do anything
not to be painted in such a bad light in
the media
all right that's a good that's a good
one uh
look the whole reason i do this is
because i got so sick of the media
and uh the mainstream media the vast
majority there are a few exceptions but
the
the vast majority of it seems like
journalists within it and actually the
business models
do not care about us
they don't care about uh the psychology
of the world
of america there are business models
about
trauma using triggering words
creating division basing everything in
fear
it doesn't matter what angle you're
coming at it if you look deep enough
into the messages usually everything's
grounded in fear
not love not connectivity not making the
the country or the world a better place
and i
you know i'm not one of these people
that thinks oh if we you know they'll be
full peace and no
wars ever on this planet i don't i don't
agree with that that's just not going to
happen in the human species
in in my opinion but
the mainstream it's just disgusting it's
gotten to a point of
being disgusting honestly these people
will be judged very poorly
by the history books you know just like
other people
in the past things that were okay um
but society has moved on and and passed
through
whatever it might be and they're judged
poorly
i really think the mainstream media and
the journalists
of today in like 100 years they'll be
looking back on these people
like wow that was that was a savage
group of people they were looking they
were pitting
society against each other for money and
trying to make them hate each other
and by doing the more they could do that
the more money they can make the better
their business did the more praise they
got at work
because they had more likes or followers
or whatever it is right
so think about think of these
journalists that you know might
the real myopic ones that just go in one
way
negatively in a story
and get rewarded for that at work
in society i guess because they become
more famous
it's disgusting stuff so back to your
question
what can jews do to paint a better image
it's it's i think just
being friendly to people i think that's
just an easy step you can do on your own
right like what i felt about hasidim
from the outside i'm like these are
these are people that think they're
better than me and
they don't say hi back guy cut me in
line
you know they want to have nothing to do
with the outside world
there's some truth to that they have to
stay strong there
historical context behind the reason why
they're they're very strong and
tight-knit like this is super important
for their survival it's been that way
for their survival in europe and
and and probably to some degree in the
states and
i get that um and if do you want to put
a bunch of technology in your life when
your religion is
somewhat against technology it's hard
it's tricky
but i think just being nice to people uh
that aren't
acidic or or or jewish
could be a a first step because it's
really hard to hate
you know be all down on someone when you
have a good experience with them
just you know the politeness of america
oh i hope it comes back it seems like
i haven't gone in a store front door
here other than the grocery store
because they're all closed in san
francisco but
you know holding a door for someone that
basic stuff
i think goes a long way
all right guys another question
thank you for all the uh the uh positive
words here guys in the super chats for
uh firing me up
i love it uh movin my fiance is also
ukrainian i'm
british pakistani i love your pakistani
stuff and hasinam journey have you spent
time with muslims
differences would you love to meet uh
we'd love to meet you someday love your
work okay so the islamic world
has i've done a lot of
of i've gone to a lot of muslim
countries
i did a whole series on iran i did one
on pakistan i did
one on saudi arabia i was
planning this spring to go to was going
to go to israel but then
palestine syria which i've been to
before
in lebanon yeah
that's definitely a focus point and i
want to mubin i want to go deep in on
islam in america so dearborn michigan
for example i think that's the biggest
community
i that's a deep dive i want to go in on
i think it's another community that
not many people know about and it's
misrepresented in
in the mainstream yeah good question
all right
okay another question here
have you ever read have you noticed any
rise in new york when it comes to
anti-sem
uh some medicine i
i'm i haven't because i'm i'm i'm not
jew so
people told me there was a arise in like
anti-semitic crime
uh which group are you heading next rw
yeah i've had to iterate because uh this
travel content's a little difficult
these days
as you might imagine and so i'm gonna be
doing a couple things on san francisco
and more about i'm actually gonna do a
video
mostly my content is about connecting
really closely with a group or people
but there's some things i feel like i
have to get out one about the news media
i'm gonna talk about moving back to
america after being gone for four years
and what i love about it believe it or
not there are many things i love about
it despite these crazy times
and then i'll have another video of like
the things i dislike about america after
living abroad for four years so these
are sort of filler videos between
which though i think they'll be
interesting good but bt in the next
community and the
the cuban community really interests me
in in miami
i've been to kuma cuba and i know there
are a lot of cubans there
so i need to get those stories if any
cubans are out there
contact peter santaniello dot com
uh just put it in the title cuba and
i'll get back to you i need some good
story ideas
it's all about the people really that's
why this series worked is because i had
shlomi
and he brought me in to very interesting
people and
that's what makes it
trailer park america yeah i'm super
interested i'm super interested in
getting into say the forgotten part of
america appalachia
i really want to do a deep dive there i
think there's another group of people
that have been misrepresented
in the mainstream media and been have
looked you know been looked out upon
so i want to give some light into into
that community i've also heard i mean
that's a big community but like
deep deep in i also heard it's quite
closed off so i need to
i need to penetrate uh get through the
front doors there
uh dearborn contact yes please emily
send it to me
okay uh
i don't know is it it's either jaime
or chimey
right would that be it i think so
where'd you go here you are
as an ex hosid i think it's important to
point out that most people that end up
leaving the community stay close and
connected with their families and
friends
i did not know that do you hear that
guys that's
that's an interesting point i thought if
they left
they're ostracized and gone completely
and many are i think
i think it depends on the family and how
strict they are
but i did not know that very good point
thank you
shout out to shlomi yeah shlomi's the
man
who doesn't love that i mean he's the
best ambassador
for uh the religion i find like
how can he do any better than him shlomi
was shalomi was fantastic
without shlomi it just you know if i had
sort of a more of a boring person
bringing me into this place
the videos would have been much less
interesting he was amazing
okay uh beverly extreme poverty abuse
secrecy and rituals appalachia people
yeah i don't know i haven't spent any
time there it's part of the country i
don't know anything about really
and that's another point uh guys is um
most americans don't know anything about
america and most most foreigners know
nothing about america and most americans
know
nothing about america for example this
last series about has seen
like who knew that i didn't most people
didn't
and so there are all these subgroups i
think that's what makes the country so
interesting and cool
and uh it's a it's a point that's being
overlooked these days but that's really
a beautiful thing and so i want to get
into as many as i can
okay clubbed clubbed
i think club's four thank you peter uh
my people want you to be our new pr firm
you can spend the next 10 years visiting
and sharing communities in an honest and
meaningful way and earn a great living
uh yeah you know i'm
i'm not monogamous with uh cultures
and i'm saying this in a jokingly way
obviously not a sexual way but with
with cultures or uh you know countries i
really like
i'm just overall curious and i want to
know what
places and people are like usually i
take something from that and apply it to
my life and i learn something so in a
way it's a bit selfish it's like
i want to learn and if i can bring
people along for the ride like you guys
then it's
and i can create a life out of it then
it's like it's amazing and i finally got
to this place at 43.
it took me a long time to get here i've
done all sorts of jobs i didn't want to
do
but now i'm doing what i feel like i
need to be doing
so i can't stick with one community uh
to the end
but thank you okay hellman khan we
passed you in afghans or
a lost tribe of israel huh thanks for
taking us closer to the community
didn't know that for those those that
don't know the pashtun people i went
in pakistan and where they're all
passions
and is is pretty much the the front line
of invading armies into india
and these people since they've
been through so many wars they're very
uh
like if you're on their bad side um good
luck
they're they're fighters but they're
also lovers
so if you're on their good side it's
like the most hospitable type of place
i love the pashtuns thanks hellman
do colombian communities yes i've been
to colombia colombia is great if there's
a colombian community in miami
please let me know contact at
petersantonella.com
okay touched on this a little bit but
what strikes you the most about
sabbath as a non-jew
uh i like
the other again i'm realizing how
important ritual is
uh i see you almost be anti-christmas
it's like oh do the same thing every
year that's silly
and now i'm seeing the how important
these
celebrations and rituals are so i i
liked when
you know they brought in the light um
before they they're taking the light in
and the discipline of not touching
lights
and just all these little details that
that um i think
well it might look not silly but
you might ask why would you even bother
doing that i think when you add them all
up and at the end
um it's an addition in life not a
subtraction
i think it's having a reset every week
makes sense i
unfortunately i'm not doing that it's
like i feel like i gotta keep
keep the machine going and i got all
these stories i got to do and i'm doing
this all alone so
i would like to get to that that reset
mode
i think we we could all use it
uh will i become jewish no i won't
nothing against judaism
i just i i don't want to change
religions
will i go to russia i was supposed to be
in russia last summer yes russia is high
on the list
russia is another one of these
misunderstood
lands it's massive it's 11 time zones
it's got all sorts of different
people in it and uh moscow and
and in the far east are two different
universes from my understanding so
yes okay daryl cuban community
say hello to my little friend say hello
to my little friend i don't understand
that one
but i will hello little friend
okay
a lot of sabbath questions i think i
covered those
um yossi thank you i
appreciate it and people like thank you
for showing it on by a side
and honestly i didn't do anything i
walked in and
asked questions why are we in a world
where we have to be
um just
i'm trying not to swear okay because i
got kids watching now so i'm
really trying to make sure my language
is always pure because i get some like
seven-year-olds watching this channel
which is cool um
why are we in a world where we have to
knock
down others i don't understand that
uh so what somebody doesn't believe what
i believe or think exactly how i think
it's just such a narcissistic way of
looking at humanity like oh you don't
agree with me
100 so you're less than me it's insanity
that that's like uh so when a journalist
goes into
the hasidic world say he gets invited in
and he only goes to knock it down that's
that's that's like a troubled person
now if there's a bad story and they're
going in on this specific story as that
angle
i get it and these and we do need
journalists to do that like that's an
important part of journalism is to cover
all angles and i'm not a journalist i
don't claim to be a journalist
we do we do need that but um
what's wrong with people like why do i
gotta go into some religion and tell
them they're doing it all wrong who am i
what do i know honestly i've been on the
planet 43 years i have my beliefs
and they they change too i think when
you're growing
oh that might that come might cause a
conflict actually because if you're
a very religious person your beliefs
don't change because
there's basically a map there's a rule
book to live by and
then i can respect that but for me
personally
you know in five years i'll be saying a
lot of different things i think my my
my core principles and fundamentals will
be the same but i will learn something
on the journey
and i might go back and say oh that
peter when he was 43 he was
he didn't know what he was talking about
with whatever and so
why why we have to live in a world where
people
go into to the other and just
talk poorly i don't know it's disgusting
i'm sick of it i think people are on
this channel because they're sick of it
too
and i try my best i'm not perfect i try
to give it
balance i try to you know i'm sure i
mess i do mess up
i'm 100 sure i do mess up sometimes
uh but that's my promise to you guys if
you stay on this channel it's like
i want to get into these people like let
people talk
and this is the crazy thing you can get
like if somebody talks
and i don't tell them they're wrong then
it must be i agree with them this is how
this is perceived sometimes in this
world that's not the truth it's like let
them talk
learn from them agree disagree but let
let people know
uh where they're coming from because if
you don't let them talk you'll never
know where their their mind space is and
like why why they're why they are doing
a certain thing or why they do think a
certain way you have to
you have to like my job is to open up
people in front of the camera
make them feel as relaxed as possible
it's why i use a gopro
it's tiny it doesn't look serious
you know i've had a big camera people
clam up more
so that's my job is to get people to
talk and then you the audience you make
your
you make your opinion however you want
uh is there anything we can do to help
you get a reset every week
x amount of patreons ah thank you um
the shama that's very sweet of you
well look i i figured out youtube you
have to post once a week
like it it pumps the algorithm and it's
good for audience too
i've really realized when i started
youtube i didn't know what i was doing
at all
and i was posting once every couple
months and so that that goes nowhere so
yeah i think i just got to get better
more efficient
maybe um but thank you that's very sweet
of you
yeah patreon's help i mean all the
support i've received helps i'm finally
making a living off all of this
which is a huge overcoming for for a
while i was running another business
and doing this so i stuck between two
worlds
and then i sold that business it gave me
a runway it was like a total
like hail mary if you know football like
i threw the ball up there and hopefully
it lands
because the money's going down and is
this youtube thing going to go anywhere
i have no idea
and now i have the confidence it is and
it can
so um you can't really do i mean
just your support watching uh patreon
whatever you want i don't expect
anything from anyone
um just having you here is a lot thank
you
okay when am i planning to come to
israel that was a springtime trip i had
planned
and then uh coveted so i don't know when
it's when it's good again to go i don't
want to go in the middle of summer it's
so hot
potentially the fall potentially the
fall
okay did i know about the
noah hyde laws i don't know about the
noahide laws
see i can show you my ignorance to a lot
of this stuff i'm the specialist in
in uh hasidum i don't know the know-how
laws i'm sure i sound like an idiot
saying that but uh please please let me
know
do jews want to distance themselves from
americans or
do they want to connect better with the
rest of us ron asked this
i have jewish friends here that
almost keep their judaism undercover
meaning they don't
like if like someone wouldn't know
they're jewish unless they knew them
well
there are some people like that and then
there's a hasidic world by just by the
way they dress you can tell they're
jewish
so it's it's complicated i think some
people
um some people are open to the outs the
the the others let's say and some aren't
just depends
okay carrie king are you thinking of
going to some more controversial
countries in africa sudan chad or
venezuela
yeah the world is open for me i'm not
going to put myself in
like direct danger for content there are
better people for that that are you know
probably not married and younger that
will do a lot of risk
i'm not so if a situation i i have a
risk tolerance i'll go into a place but
if like
the drc for example i don't think that
would be smart to go shoot
video in right now i don't know i
haven't researched it but
sudan i think is a definitely a go chad
i don't know anything about venezuela
depends
if i had a really good contact i think i
would need that there
so yes but no
not going into a war zone um
you know some people think i do what i
do is very risky others think it's not
risky at all it depends your risk
tolerance
okay can i do a series on muslims in new
york i'm not in new york for a little
bit
uh i would like to though i do
want to go deep on the muslim content
and know what's interesting is you know
some people are going to like this and
some people aren't but
wow what a lot of similarities between
the hasidic
uh hasidics in uh people practicing
muslim i mean islam seriously like a lot
of
similarities obviously everything comes
from the torah originally
right and now the books of chain the
religions the abrahamic religions are
all different but it
the foundations in the torah so
a lot of similarities
how about the covet vaccine
ah that's a tough one my mom's gonna
take it
which i think she should i'm no expert
on this i haven't done a deep enough
dive
for me personally i'll wait
i'll wait
okay belarus uh someone asking it was so
dangerous when i was in belarus when i
was in belarus uh a summer and a half
ago it wasn't dangerous at all it was
totally safe now
well last summer i don't think it was
well i know it wasn't in a good place i
don't know what it's like right now
passing down values okay yvonne what did
i learn about passing down values to the
next generation
i'm guessing you're referring to hasidum
well there are a lot of
rituals and those obviously get passed
down
i think the biggest threat the biggest
threat to all of us really is technology
right and how do you
like it was said many times it can
either be your best friend or your worst
enemy
so we we can do this in the series we
could you know
exchange ideas and and teach each other
and that's the beauty of it but
it's addictive stuff how do you make it
not addictive
because it's designed to be addictive
it's designed to like take our time
and so acetum is almost the opposite end
of that it needs to be away from that
but then it's touching on that it's
complicated
and what i could see a little
light failure what i could see is um
the technology is uh
it's for some people it's not a clear
black and white
even in hasidum some people are using it
a lot some people aren't using it at all
so it's almost like who you talk to
and let's not forget humans are humans i
i was a rebellious kid there are
rebellious kids
in every community i remember being in
saudi arabia and
some people talking about not drinking
alcohol
and and then i remember seeing a couple
that was it was like 10 in the morning
or no
maybe seven or eight in the morning and
they were in their car drunk from the
night before
and they were practicing muslims and if
you ask them on the surface
you know their dedication to islam it
was very strong
but at the end of the day they're doing
other things
in every community so
it's easier to give like specific labels
and like
this is black and white but the reality
is it's not at all i try to i try to
capture that
uh moshi thank you i appreciate it thank
you
i'm not a effin racist okay good don't
be
racist people suck uh
what do i think of the synagogue i i
went into one synagogue it was it was
cool
i didn't spend much time in there it was
uh it was like right
near the metro tracks the the subway
tracks it was super loud in there when
the train went by
but it was it had a feel to it it had a
very
deep feel to it
all right guys a few more questions what
are we coming up oh we'll we'll go at
least an hour i'll say
and then uh i'll answer a few more here
when are you going back to pakistan uh
not sure i would love to
that's this is one of those
misunderstood countries in the west at
least and uh
a beautiful one on many levels
so i have to cover more there
okay uh jay joca says what would you say
makes hasinam stand out different from
other cultures that are more reserved
such as amish or monks etc
i don't know the amish i need to get
into that community
that's that's like high on the list
um monks i did live in thailand i was
introduced to
well it depends what type of monk i'm
sorry monks
everything's the same and everything's
different how about that
like a lot of similar structures of
discipline but a lot of
um differences in
behavior let's say the way they approach
people in the world
that's a deep dive though basically i i
did some double speak and
it didn't make any sense but uh
that's a whole topic to talk about
favela thank you
how is kosher food i don't i don't know
it tastes like
the food was good but when it's kosher
it's not kosher how do you tell the
difference
like it's been blessed obviously but uh
as far as the taste i don't know i had
good food though
jehovah's witness community yeah that
would be interesting i know nothing
about it
okay a lot coming through i'm trying not
to repeat repeat questions
oh do you think you're really good okay
how um
brooklyn okay how well of a grip do you
think you really got in the community do
you think you might
have been shown a censored
view of the community of you that looks
good on camera okay so
how well do i know it i mean how well
can anyone know it after say a week and
a half
of anything so not that well
what i do know is
sounds cheesy but humanity and and
connecting with people and talking i
know
how to converse with people listen to
people
so the people i met
were were fantastic okay
i don't think it was like some north
korean pre-arranged
uh look at the best of our community and
like
you know put everything behind the
closed doors type experience i think
who i saw was representative of a lot of
people in the community
now shlomi is he gonna bring me into the
person that's suffering and living a
terrible life
uh to expose his uh community to the
world of course not because that's
that's what most people have seen so i
know it's not a balanced story i didn't
go into a
great family uh let's just say if i
could a
family that's really healthy and
function well there's shabbat dinner
and then go into a family that's
completely dysfunctional with all sorts
of problem and shoot their shabbat
dinner
that would be the most balanced view but
then you have to say how what percentage
is healthy versus which is unhealthy
which how do you even determine that
so censored i won't say censored in the
true definition i think
whenever you're trying to show something
off like if someone
um i can look at the flaws of america
but overall i'm going to be an
optimistic
if i'm abroad and someone asked me about
america i'm going to not do it in a
nationalistic way like
i'm better than you but i'll do it in a
patriotic way saying
these are the attributes this is what i
think is great about the country here
are some of the things that aren't as
great but i'm going to be heavier on
the great and so i think that's just
human when someone wants to
show you off whatever it is
so is it the most um balanced
series no not at all and i try to
mention that i try to mention
a few times i was probably repetitive
like there's a story in this building
and someone's living a good life and
someone's not and you have to understand
that when you're shooting
that's the power of the edit like people
that don't make videos
i could even make the most positive
thing i could make that shabbat dinner
look terrible
i mean that would be hard actually they
were so happy and having such a good
time but i could use narration
i could shoot it in a weird way and even
make a negative out of that so it's
really the power of the creator and so
an objective and keep that in mind
my objective is to
show countries that have been poorly
uh received in the world or looked
looked down upon because of
media or whatever or or people or
ethnicities not
much people many people know about
and bring out the good so that's that's
what i can add to the world
it would honestly i'd be a much more
popular channel if i just went in and
destroyed things and
and and looked at the worst of this and
that that's honestly what that
triggers people and and sells the best
let's say
but my my angle is i got so sick of
you know i went around the world when i
was 24 to 26.
i worked two jobs for two years to save
the money and i always
we never traveled growing up and i
wanted to see the world i went around 50
countries and came home
and people are asking me where i like
never seen things like places like the
republic of georgia and they're like
in a negative way why would you go there
why why what's what's the point of going
there and i said now the food the people
the landscape
yeah i get it politically it's a basket
case of a country but
and so i realized at that point in time
the only exposure
most people have the most places is
negative so i wanted to give a different
angle on that and through the human
element not to the political one
so that's where i come from you know
what cnn and fox going to come at you
with
they're going to hit they're going to
hit a specific angle and it's going to
evoke a reaction most likely negative
i look at i look at all the mainstream
news just to see what's being reported
how it's being reported
and uh and what's not being reported
that's the most interesting
like what people are just not reporting
because it doesn't fit their narrative
or agenda
everyone has an agenda i have an agenda
you have an agenda
uh if you're hasidic and you've been
looked down upon by the outside world
you have an agenda to
say no no guys it's not all like what
you were told okay there's some cool
stuff going on here
so i want to be as transparent as
possible with you guys on that
and if i'm ever slipping please i i
really
i really focus on being as authentic and
true as i can
and as non-judgmental as i can that's
that's
my goal in every video i do okay uh
eliza
really enjoyed the series as i do with
all of your shoes thank you would you
consider doing something slightly
different and check out the world of
normal trump supporters to contrast how
they portrayed in the media
yeah that that annoys me i have a lot of
family members that voted
uh voted for trump and they're really
good people
and i understand why they did and i
understand why a lot of people did i
understand why people voted each i
didn't even vote because i was so
i was so pissed off with the options and
that's that's my that's my decision and
my choice
and my right and i think you're right
like
a lot of i have to do in a way where i
don't get like
totally political because the second you
do that the content
the content silos up into into a group
so i have to do it in a way where it's
um
through a human story of some sort not
just directly saying it whenever you
directly say something like
if i just said hey the hasidic people
are great and and they're amazing
and uh you know just made this you know
just
briefly told you how to think you'd say
yeah whatever guy
but if i can show you something and if i
can humanize something and make a
personal connection emotional connection
that to me has the most power
against the other forces that we're
dealing with
so yeah i wanna i wanna i wanna show i
wanna show that
for sure i gotta do it the right way
though
i know the cubans um
the cuban americans i think mostly voted
trump
and so why is that and why aren't people
curious why don't you want to know
you know i'm not saying you guys but i'm
just saying in general like why did they
do that
why would they and i think that's where
we need to get at
as a society is be like so why does like
where's somebody coming from
mentally and from their experiences
you know which leads to this action and
why are they doing that and that's where
we're failing in society is like not
asking like why in in and not a not
like why in a sorry scary
like why so why why would you do that
like let them open
i'm gonna try
all right excited to see series on cuba
thank you ashley uh i don't have it yet
that's
a lot of the stress believe it or not it
all looks fun on camera
but i i this is my life this is what
consumes me
pretty much all waking hours and i don't
have any stories yet and i gotta make
two videos edit two videos and i'm like
i'm like
just some things that didn't work out in
the schedule and like
a lot of this is luck really and a lot
of me
might just be going to miami and like
just walking around
and talking to some people and then i
find a really interesting people and
then i'm like hey if i come back and we
talk about this on camera and
it might be something like that it might
be something completely spontaneous
that i get lucky with and that's the
contents that's usually the most
interesting is like the spontaneous
stuff people want like this real
connectivity i think that's what i want
when i watch stuff so
yeah you just you just stress me out in
a good way i'm like yeah i gotta nail it
because every every series i go into i'm
like
i'm nervous like i won't get the content
it won't be interesting enough and then
then what you know so
yeah i really do want to hit cuba
america well okay uh rivka i appreciate
the courageous positive represent
representation you're you're so
respectful i believe your viewers gain
uh in a respectful resp uh per cut i can
read
perspective from your work thank you
rivka uh
like we all want to be respected that's
that's just
i want to be respected so if i don't if
i disrespect then i'm not going to get
respect so what's
you know it's pretty simple right
i i don't i don't know why these are um
big things to be honest they should be
fundamentals like air and water and
food uh eric's electric
empire hi peter love your content
especially your new series by the way as
a cuban most voted for trump because of
communism and fear
interesting yeah i've heard of that i've
heard that to some degree so eric if you
have any good stories cuban stories in
miami
contact petersantonello.com
contact peter santana dot com
so that's where cubans are coming out
come at it coming at it from they left a
system
where this is from my understanding and
my time spending
you know in in cuba they they left a
system where most people could not
realize themselves who they wanted to be
in this world
and the state made a lot of the decision
making
and basic things
were harder to obtain material things
let's say
you know if it's communist i'm
understanding religion was probably
suppressed pretty low
so there's no perfect system i could see
beauty despite that and i could see
beauty in cuba i felt that people were
more connected
and maybe because there was a lower
economic socioeconomic status people
needed each other more
perhaps um but i would love to get into
that
really would i loved your country cuba
was was the cuban people
like not the cuban government but the
cuban people were fantastic
a lot to be learned from you guys for
sure
um peter please visit palestine they are
struggling in an apologist
okay um and i'm not saying okay like no
i just don't want to go down the
political
rabbit hole right now because uh
i just know what that turns into uh they
are beautiful yes
i um i've been to palestine i went to
i went to rabala i think it was i went
to parts of the west bank in rabala
i met great people i met great people on
both sides
that's the most complex uh situation
right and i want to cover both sides
equally and fairly and try not to go
into
uh the politics that runs it but that's
pretty much impossible in that part of
the world i think
but i really do want to go um you know
i'm going to show this
this israeli side of things and i'm
going to show this palestinian side
and you take take it for whatever it is
the coolest thing i ever saw about
israel and palestine was this
documentary called promises
it was a long time ago but from what i
remember was like
i don't know five or ten kids that were
um jewish and five or ten that were
uh palestinian and it was a beautiful
documentary it showed them from like
when they're
really young and how they grew up
through life
in their relationship because they were
very close in the beginning as kids
because kids are kids they don't see any
of this stuff they don't care about
politics
and um really an interesting one
promises
i got to re-watch it
funny
all right guys a couple more questions
and i'm gonna bounce um
let me see if i've hit all these super
chats
i think i did if i didn't i'm trying my
best here
i'm trying to scroll through i think i
got all those
it's what i'm seeing on my end at least
and if i didn't get your if i didn't
answer your super chat it's not because
i'm avoiding it i'm just
scrolling through and i think i answered
all the ones i've saw i've seen
and i will i'll give you a direct
message at contact at peter santaniello
if i miss it because i'm trying not to
miss it
[Music]
i was wondering if you're aware that the
majority of orthodox jews are not
hasidic yes i know this
hasidic from the outside i think there's
a couple things it's the most
um just the word hasidic in english to
me sounds
sounds like tough like ukraine
just the word how it sounds in english
is like
ukraine it's like
and hasidic has always been like
used with say the extreme
or the the outcast or the censored or
the repressed or whatever and so i
really wanted to focus just on
that and i understand or there's so many
levels
of judaism
okay a couple more questions
thank you m choir appreciate it
thank you
do you think tolerance this is a good
question leah uh
do you think tolerance needs to be
taught or it should be instinctual
i think it needs to be taught
i think um number one in our education
system should be critical thinking
skills that should be the number one
thing to be taught because we're getting
so much information
and everything's coming at us with an
angle or an agenda and to be able to
think
critically and so interesting coming
back to america this time and hearing
you know about how america is so racist
you know
i've been out of the country for four
years
i'm thinking through this and i'm like
of all the places i've traveled to
america is actually one of the least
racist places now hear me out as as many
of you might have
dealt with racism in your life
racism exists everywhere that's for sure
america is one of the few countries in
the world where all the animals from the
zoo
are in the same cage and they sort of
get along actually like i deal with
people from all different backgrounds
every day even during the pandemic time
i'm not dealing with too many people but
in any of these american cities
especially in new york you're like
talking to this guy from this background
that person from that background like
and it it it mostly works
like i love it it's a beautiful thing
like who bagged my um i was at trader
joe's yesterday and who was there behind
the register there was a black woman and
there was an
asian woman and there was me and my wife
were all from my wife from ukraine
um we all have different ethnic
backgrounds and we're all joking and
hanging out together and talking
and when i look at a playground in new
york you know
sometimes they're segregated like you
know people are tribal it's just how
you know many humans are it's it's in
the dna
but i think america does one of the best
jobs of like
dismantling a lot of the tribalism at
least down to a level where you can
interact every day at a human
basic level which is amazing
what is the question i forgot i got on a
tangent
so this has been one of the big things
where i'm like yes
there is racism here yeses exists yes
hasidic jews have definitely been and
jews in general
have dealt with all sorts of racism you
don't need to hear from me that there's
no racism that's that's
that's lame um but as a whole as a
country
i mean try being um try being afghani in
iran
good luck on that that's going to be a
lot of fun like the law is not going to
work for you the same way
and there's so many tribing uyghur in in
china
i mean that's hardcore racism that's
though that's the most
disgusting where they're put in
basically camps these days and
yes it exists here yes any races racist
people suck they're the worst
um but i do believe i i do believe
we do amazing together overall and the
narrative that we don't
is is is look at look at all
the people that have rose to the top in
this country
from all different backgrounds that's
the proof in itself
all right i forgot the question a couple
more
i said that a couple more ago
thank you goldie i appreciate it i'm
glad you got something something out of
it
uh tony anything changed
after my conversation with the rabbi
would you meet him again
i answered that earlier someone else
asked me that that's a very popular
question and
i think the rabbi had a lot of
a lot of good wisdom i didn't agree with
everything he said but he
he did
make a lot of sense now that i'm married
and i'm i'm 100 committed to my
relationship and i
i see how structure and uh
let's just say some of the
old-fashionedness
is is almost like fresh air like
i want i want stability in my
relationship i don't want to
uh you know relationships ebb and flow
they're stronger they're weaker at times
i get it but
there's some basic principles that he
said that made a lot of sense
so i would talk to him again yeah sure
uh do i think i do i'll do more vlogs
with shlomi down the road yeah
yeah why not he's great he's informative
well spoken
charismatic great on camera
thank you daryl appreciate it
florida kosher villas thank you
appreciate it
muslim american series i'm repeating now
um
yes for sure that's that's one of the
top ones i want to get into the native
americans i want to get into the inuits
up in uh way north how do they look at
america i want to get
into some far fringes of society because
that's what america
is it's many fringes it's not just uh
l.a new york
chicago miami san francisco america is a
massive
massive place and here's a crazy thing
i love america more than i've ever loved
it before despite all the we're
dealing with oh excuse my language uh
despite all the
problems we're dealing with i
after living abroad and traveling you
know 90 plus countries and living in
four countries there's no perfect place
for everyone
what works for me isn't going to work
for someone else but as far as
what i value in my personality type i'm
i
i very much love this place and i hope
we get through this this
this insane time we're in i think we
will but
um there's a lot of good here that's
being overlooked right now and
the media definitely doesn't care about
helping us along that's for sure
shlomi is also watching hey shlomi
who doesn't love shlomi he's like the
most like i don't think he he could ever
have an enemy and this guy in shlomi for
those that don't know
watch his channel in his series i mean
i mean i have courage going to saudi
arabia
or iran shlomi is going in as a hasidic
jew
to saudi arabia i mean just that on
paper alone sounds
that sounds high risk
and he's coming out with these amazing
experiences and he shows that on his
channel
and i think shalom has a big part in the
jewish community he's
he's really the star here because he
without shalom i wouldn't have gotten it
any of this stuff
impossible not happening like a knock on
someone's door can i come to your
shabbat dinner i'm just going to bring
my camera and make a video out
you know about it for youtube okay
nobody's going to say come on
in it's only because shlomi i got in all
these places
and he gets it he's very true to his
religion
he's acidic obviously but he gets
the outside world he gets many countries
he's traveled a lot
so he's the he's the perfect bridge
because he knows how to explain
and say dumb it down to a person like me
who doesn't know much about his
his uh his religion and say it in simple
terms
and really create that bridge so uh
yes i hope to do something with shalom
in the future and
got big things slow me you gotta you
gotta go on this thing with the youtube
you gotta go regular
you're busy man um you are posting but i
really think you have
like a lot a lot to give the world
like really can almost change
the way people view uh your religion
so shalom is the man
okay
what is it 109. i'm going to go till
115. how about that it's
uh five five and a half more minutes
then we'll call it good
can you also go into the palestine part
of israel
love to interesting i i think um you
know i've been to that
i've been to israel and palestine before
as a tourist you really don't know
anything ever
uh and that's just super complex
and so many layers going on there so i'd
like to i'd like to get
at least you know peel back the onion a
little bit in my content
[Music]
okay miss gi or gl
this series has been such a comfort to
me i appreciate what you do a lot
what you have done has opened a lot of
people's eyes to understanding some
customs thank you
and shalom thank you miss gl
look we're all dying for this right now
i think i'm i'm
doing it honestly because it fills a
need in me where i
like it just feels like a lack of
if you're not really religious and you
don't have
all the all of these customs to adhere
to cohere to
it's like um what's the purpose right
now it feels like society is
like anything you look at
it's hard to see much purpose in it at
least for me
and um
i find purpose and this is honestly i
don't know what i would be doing if i
wasn't doing this now i would have to
become
i would have to find something because
it's just we're in such weird times huh
and so um if i've been a comfort to you
miss
miss gi gl then then then thank you
you're a comfort to me all you guys are
a comfort to me because
nobody cared about this then i'd be i i
honestly think i'd
still do it just for my sanity uh but it
would be really hard
right uh it'd be it'd
be brutal so um
cool we're in this together
oh interesting question um deborah
what surprised you most about the
hasidic women that you met
the ones that i met
were very with it open and seem to be
in charge of their lives now i don't
know what's behind the scenes i didn't
you know
i didn't you know there's only so far i
can go but
yeah i i was surprised i thought they
would have been much more repressed
and and also one caveat
i'm not the most religious people are
going to be nowhere near me
or a camera that's just how it is
so i'm going to make this point for
those that i didn't see the beginning of
this
just in hasidum there's labovich
i'd say labovich is on this side correct
me if i'm wrong someone and then um
hasidic is on this side pacific i mean
uh
sorry lobovich and sabar satmar is on
this side
i wasn't i'm not going to be able to
dive deep on the satmar
uh shilomi said there's something like
200 sex in his sedum
so the most conservative that's a no-go
not happening so i wasn't talking with
those people
i was talking with people that are going
to be brave enough
to be on a camera so that should tell
you something too
and i also want to say if someone
doesn't want to be on camera i don't
think there's anything wrong with that
i get it they're trying to trying to
hold on to some principles and some
meaning in this world
so something we're all sort of craving
so i get it
uh thank you m choir
i'm sure okay
all right guys two more minutes what
else do we got here
how about korea uh south korea or north
korea i'd be up for both
okay
have i been to riyadh yes i made an uh i
made a video on riyadh
my first day in saudi arabia
interesting place if i could travel back
to a period of time when would it be
you know i almost look like i feel like
i did like i traveled before
like early 2000s before the internet was
really there before you travel with your
phone and i look back with with such
great nostalgia right now because
things were just so much more raw and
you had to rely more on your intuition
and
uh the people you interact you know
encountered i couldn't always just get
on my phone and get a hotel that sort of
thing so
i live that but i think um
that's a good question i don't know
anywhere anywhere far back there's many
different time periods i think it would
have been interesting
hi peter and schlemme i'm trying to
convert to judaism even
and even if it's difficult i honestly
love where you think about the journey
uh think about jesus cool
cool yeah i think it's i asked the
question on the last video because i
wasn't so sure on how you do it and a
lot of people left answers so you might
be able to get some information there
anything i learned that i would apply
from it to my life yes a lot
there's a lot to be learned from
communities that let's just call them
what they are communities
that really help each other and have
institutions set up
for all things that can go wrong in life
there's something behind that and
uh that's a beautiful thing
la is this my last video about jews
hasidic or not no i won't say it's my
last it's my last of this series
i have a global audience um some people
are like do more of these
hasidic jew jewish videos or do more uh
jewish videos
some are like okay peter you've gone 13
episodes on
on a topic you've never gone that deep
or long on something time to move on
i'm never going to please everyone so
for now now
now i'm going to totally break it up and
i hope
as the hasidic
many hasidic jewish people have gotten
something out of this um because
people have looked into their community
because they've been curious
i hope a lot of you and i'm not just
saying telling you to you know stay on
my channel but
i hope you keep the curiosity towards
others too like i'm gonna if i go into
the community
when i go into the cuban community or
the muslim community
this is this is what's going to
um bridge a lot of the divide i think
so i i can i can promise you some
interesting adventures to come
i i live and breathe this stuff so
getting into the right people in the
right worlds is everything
and america has so many of these and the
pandemic moved my wife and i back here
and there's i i really am all about
showing american content and i never
thought i would be i thought oh that's
my home country boring whatever
no now i'm super fascinated with it for
those of you
that have emailed to me um i'm i'm going
through them all and reading
as much as i'm reading every i will read
everyone i won't be able to respond
everyone it's just
the sheer volume i'm super humble and
and grateful to receive so much but i
i honestly can't um get back on
everything because
i'm a one-man band my wife helps me out
a little bit she's the director i call
it the director
she looks at the final cuts she says oh
you look like an idiot here
oh this looks cool here okay change this
around a little bit
she's a big help but other than that
it's just me um
and i'm pretty much maxed out i'm
probably not the most efficient editor
and uh yeah i haven't even read a book
it's killing me
i'm not even reading at all i have a
stack of like eight books
um but i'm just so like
immersed and passionate about this work
it takes precedent over everything else
so
emails if i didn't get back to you
please don't take it personally i just i
just
don't have the bandwidth i wouldn't be
able to make videos if i if i got back
to every every message
is not possible right now um future
series again i'm going to be doing a
couple things here
in san francisco i think you guys will
find interesting
and then i'm going to miami a story that
really interests me is the cuban
story there if you have any good cuban
contacts
uh contact petersantonello.com
just write it in the in the title cuban
miami
and um that's about it guys got a lot
more on the horizon though
uh this year is going to be a big one a
lot of subgroups in america
and then as many of you have requested
and as i
had planned to do last spring israel
and palestine uh we could definitely use
some humanizing content over there
so thank you all stay strong through
these uh crazy times um
be kind to people let's let's stay
together
and get through this weirdness i'm in
san francisco where
it's uh it's it's crazy it's like
it's like i'm in a black mirror episode
society's all scared of one another
most people i get it people are very
scared about pandemic i get it but
you know it doesn't mean we can't look
at each other anymore
or say hi at distance with a mask on
outside
you know i i just looking forward to get
through this
and uh the hisidic world felt like it
like in
like a like a like an island with a palm
tree and a beach compared to this
because it was like okay people are
smiling and talking and being human that
was very nice
okay with that said all you guys thank
you so much uh
love you for caring about uh this
content
and um and i'm doing my best to uh
to show places and people that that most
people don't know about so
okay until the next video take care